aaron rodgers
was and still is a big fan of the office
and
one of the best things about the office
they do those testimonials all the time
and no matter what happens good bad or
otherwise right they always find the
positive in it right they're shutting
down the branch
one after another oh it's a positive
they're not shutting down the branch one
after another oh it's a positive i mean
come on and look i am becoming a
gigantic aaron rodgers fan
but don't give me this stuff that it was
good to get curb stomped yesterday by
the tampa bay buccaneers there's nothing
good about you had two weeks to get
ready for that game and that's what you
put on the field and that's somehow a
good thing come on chris come on no i
mean i hear you but you know how
athletes are mike you know that's the
way it goes i mean they're going to try
to find some silver lining you know more
times than not too in those type of
games and a blowout loss we've gone
through this too you go back and you
watch the game a few weeks later and you
go man two or three plays and that game
could have been totally different i mean
i think you know there is a case to be
made to that i mean
wait wait hold on hold on hold on and
aaron rodgers yeah he can say all he
wants to say
you're right but those two or three
plays we're talking about were certainly
him this time around it was nobody else
on the team anything like that he
definitely struggled yesterday and yeah
he was the jump off point for the big
turnaround with the pick six and
everything right there to where it fell
apart um so yeah i get it i know it i
know what he's trying to say but that
wasn't a good loss it didn't look good
they got dominated they got beat up i
mean uh i would have a hard time i think
in a few weeks looking back at that and
going oh it was just a few plays and i
think it was that you know it would have
been different i i'd be a little bit
worried if green bay had to see this
team again later on down the road
yeah i'm done with that two or three
plays crap here's why last year as the
packers were getting ready to play the
49ers in the playoffs i went back to the
sunday night game and i convinced myself
just two or three plays well that was
all it was that was yours
if it had gone differently if those two
or three plays go differently 49ers may
have lost that game to the packers i
think the packers can go out there and
beat the 49ers they've gone into this
bob greasy offense where they're afraid
of jimmy garoppolo and aaron rodgers
that's going back to
all that stuff roll it up in the ball
and throw it out the window they got the
crap kicked out of them twice and here's
the thing about the matlab floor packers
who are very very good in the regular
season now 17 and four yeah but when
they lose
they don't screw around no they don't
they don't they don't hold you in
suspense they had the one loss to philly
late september of 2019 at home on a
thursday night that was a close one
there are other three losses under matt
lafleur in the regular season let's
throw in the playoff loss as well
four total losses over the past two
years right where they have had the crap
kicked out of them i mean it either goes
their way start to finish or
it doesn't and it's over and pack up the
stuff and get on the plane and go home
that mike i mean that that's it that's
that's green bay that's why they're an
underwhelming 13-3 team last year i mean
in a lot of ways and it's why
i think you know after yesterday and
even going into this a little bit i've
had i had questions still about their
defense and some of those things there
but the big thing
and what we've seen through the aaron
rodgers bat lefleur era and the way the
team is built they are built to have a
lead in a football game that's the way
they are built hey we're going to come
out laford will have a few cool plays
roger's going to be efficient he's going
to hit a few big ones to get us down
there close to score we're going to get
a 10 or a 14-3 lead early in the game
and now we got these good pass rushers
and mike pettin's kind of creative and
crazy on the back end and it plays into
their hands but yes when you see that
ooh the offense is struggling and the
other team gets to play balanced
football and do things like that they're
they they have a hard time it's not
their type of game and i think again
that was exposed yesterday that's one of
the things that worries me about green
bay
and i think you know there's a little
fugaziness about how good they are as a
football team i think rogers masks that
a lot of weeks
with his efficient play and some of his
play
i'm aware of fugazi yeah i don't know
that fugaziness is it it's official
i like it yeah you like it i like i like
fugaziness okay
yeah yesterday went from oh aaron
rodgers oh oh aaron rodgers yeah bruce
arians after the game buccaneers coach
explaining how they confused one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time
you don't usually get aaron confused and
that's one thing i don't think i've ever
seen him confused but when you start
running him down and chasing him out
there early in the game he chased that
and he made a lot of plays we just kept
chasing and hemmed him up a little bit
[Music]
oh they definitely hemmed him up and how
about domikin sue settling some old
scores remember the time yeah when sue
stepped on
the lower leg of aaron rodgers back at
the time when he had a calf injury and
sue got suspended for a game for a
playoff game one of the few years that
the lions actually made the playoffs
appealed it and won
and i don't think this argument saved
the day but one of the arguments he made
was it was really cold that day at
lambeau field and his foot was numb and
he didn't know where he was stepping so
there was something there there was some
heat there going
both ways and to his credit a guy who
doesn't make plays like he used to he
wasn't quite aaron donald but he was the
closest thing to aaron donald that's
right
yeah he still when he flashes he flashes
like against the chargers forcing the
fumble that sparked the
the 17-point comeback and then yesterday
he was one of the main reasons why aaron
rodgers was so battered and bruised and
rattled yeah i mean the the bucks d it's
got really big time potential that's why
i mike i i sit here and i still think
yeah i know the bucks are sitting here
at four and two but i'm not so sure
they're not the most complete team in
the nfc i they're still a work in
progress
but what is what are the weaknesses of
the bucks you know somebody tell me what
where's an area on the team where you go
oh that's a weakness i mean the d-line
is the real deal and that was the big
difference in the game you're right i
mean sue is a force
he does pop a handful of times he's
immovable in the run game so like his
bad plays are just like oh stalemate at
the line of scrimmage you have three
guys blocking me and i didn't move i
mean that's that's the kind of guy he is
but
we haven't seen rogers under pressure
like that and confused like that i don't
think since the 49ers the last year in
those two games where we saw you know
feet hopping around and hey the pocket's
clean just chill out it's all good and
then you know oh i think this guy's
opening the pump fakes and they're
pulling it back and doing all those
things so i'm i'm excited to see the
back end of that you know film and see
what todd bowles did to kind of trick
him that way but either way they won the
physical battle and it looks like they
won the schematical battle just watching
on sunday we're talking about the
running game and you know not long ago
aaron jones the toast of the league with
that big game that he had against the
lions 10 carries 15 yards yesterday
that's what i mean though a lot of yards
per carry with the lead conversation
because
it is a team that yeah we get the lead
now we can run the ball but you can't
totally sell out on the run because we
might burn you with the big play action
pass and do those things and it lends
itself to
okay yes a crack here a crack there and
aaron jones takes advantage of it but
yeah i mean you know again i know tampa
lost that thursday night game to the
chicago bears i think we're seeing that
chicago is better than we want to give
him credit for
and this tampa team
i mean has real potential when you look
at the nfc right mike right now you go
the seahawks yeah we know but their
defense is horrible
you know and then you look at green bed
i think there's questions about that
defense as well you start to go damn is
tampa i mean new orleans i mean they're
they're right in the mix of that
conversation for me i don't know how you
feel about it well a few weeks ago we
had kind of agreed it was seahawks
packers bucks and tampa loses to chicago
and we have our doubts about them at
three and two when it felt like they
were putting something together
and now that the
buccaneers have beaten the packers you
gotta say maybe it is seahawks bucks
packers seahawks packers bucks maybe
it's bucks by the time it's all said and
done from the standpoint of having a
complete team that can win in january
that's the key right setting yourself up
to win in january and that seahawks
defense unless it improves is not going
to be the kind of unit that wins in
january especially if they have to go on
the road chris although right now
you know the good news is for them
packers losing they're uh the last
unbeaten team in the nfc right right
yeah i mean they're they're they're
sitting pretty in a good spot right now
and we know that that could be an
important spot this year to get that
first round by and do all those things
but yeah there's a lot of football to be
played here i mean green bay of course
still has to play the bears twice they
got a lot of other teams on the schedule
here and tampa we know is still a work
in progress but you know again we see
yesterday defensive play makers we've
talked about the front seven the
secondary i know we've had conversations
about it's talented but raw and messes
up every now and then but you saw
yesterday the talent it does have and
then they can run the ball and they can
pass protect and brady is getting more
and more comfortable within the offense
i mean chris godwin was less than a
hundred percent yesterday and mike evans
didn't even play they scored 38 on the
tampa bay buccaneer i mean on the green
bay packers uh i i think that's that
should be a warning shot across the nfc
bow right there to go uh oh bucks might
be figuring this out
and the defense really was key i mean
you think about what you're saying if
the packers build a lead that's when
they can do the things that allow them
to to compound it and to just pull away
well they're up 10 nothing yeah and uh
and then all of a sudden it's 38 to 10.
i mean it didn't happen quite that
quickly but it turned fast it's 10
nothing and it's 14 10 and it's 21 10
along the way to pick six here's aaron
rodgers on the key moment where things
turned with the pick six on and why the
pick six happened
yeah i mean it happens you know it's
probably
i haven't had a lot of those over the
years but um you know the wind was
blowing pretty good right to left like i
said i felt good about the spot i knew
he was tight we fit throws like that
uh i missed my spot by you know probably
a foot or so
um and the
kid made a good play
he had to squeeze in that i haven't had
a lot of yeah he did we know we know
aaron we know you're one of our best
sellers
we understand right we understand that's
what makes it more glaring when it
happens though it does it does we don't
you don't see him make those well that's
ten nothing lead ron rodgers never turns
the ball over he's efficient he throws
you know he throws for 70 percent and
they're hard to beat that way you know
but that's that's not the case yesterday
and yeah that ball you know
didn't look like rogers like uncorked it
you know or just unleashed the the
kraken to say i'm gonna throw my
fireball in here at a hundred miles per
hour
and devonte adams i think the way he ran
the route and kind of attacked demps he
was a young corner out of auburn i think
he thought like oh he's not going to run
the go route rogers kind of stared him
down and this kid jamal dean was kind of
staring in the backfield the whole time
too having a view of rogers and how he
was setting up and made a good break and
made a good play you know but then the
crazy thing is you go okay
green bay might be able to do something
get something going and then they throw
the next interception
and that's a play again it's adams to
it's aaron rodgers to devonte adams a
slant route tight window but devonte
adams hasn't played in a while ball goes
off his hands intercepted two yard
touchdown run a few plays later and then
still mike you go
green bay is not out of this and then
rogers misses a big throw down the left
sideline to aaron jones where he bobbles
it and then misses mercedes-lewis and
that to me was where i was like wait oh
they had a chance to kind of regain some
momentum and maybe get down a field goal
position and it didn't happen and then
tampa just stamped on their stump uh
stamped on their throat what
stomped on their throat stomp yeah stop
it stepped stamped whatever hey here's
here's here's a glimpse into in real
time how how jarring it was yeah i was
sitting in my normal position watching
the games while i'm trying to line up
the various phone calls that i make
after the one o'clock eastern time games
and it's ten nothing and i heard you
saying um
looks like the packers you know yeah
they have their way with the bug
poetically so yeah so i go over to the
position where i sit to take notes and
do a couple of these phone calls and i
look down at my phone and my son texted
me aaron rodgers pick six and i'm
thinking well that's interesting and
then i you know finish the phone call
come back and it's 14 10. it's like what
the hell happened that's how quick it
happens and once that once that flipped
on the packers it it felt like there was
nothing they could do about it no and
it's out of their control it gets back
to your original point
you you have to find a way to short
circuit them early or
they are going to to ultimately stomp on
your throat you have to get on theirs or
they're going to get on yours and it
doesn't happen very often it's like a
aaron rodgers pick six doesn't happen
very often but when it happens
uh it's it's ugly and it makes you
wonder can they avoid it
when the season's on the line that's the
key if they get to the playoffs well you
know even if the even if the road to the
super bowl goes through lambeau field i
think it's
with no fans it's not as critical as it
would be but who knows what'll be
happening by january but it just feels
like whether it's two whether it's three
steps to get to the super bowl or in the
super bowl itself
can they avoid
what happened yesterday for an entirety
of a postseason i'm not sure they can
i'm not sure they can either i think it
would have to fall their way you know
they'd have to be very fortunate to you
know somehow find a way to yeah where it
just fell their way to the first round
matchup as a team that's not really
complete or they match up well whatever
that may be but uh yes i have questions
i think what we're both saying is play
off football against complete football
teams and
they they kind of seem like they kind of
got to play the perfect game to me to
play those kind of games and that's just
hard that's a lot of pressure and it is
a lot on rogers when they get behind
again this goes back into the other
conversation too see it's not when you
don't have great receivers it's hard to
come back either that way so they can
they're not a great like oh we'll get in
the shootout with you type of team no
that's not green bay that was maybe
green bay seven eight years ago but not
anymore they're not like that now so
when they're down 10 14 20 points you
know the offensive pass scheme itself
is creative but not like one of the five
most creative in football where you're
just like oh they can dice anybody up
and then this you know the talent at the
receiver position
you know is probably a little better
than league wide average as far as
that's concerned maybe below average
it's below average who the hell am i
kidding and that makes it hard for them
to come back in games like yesterday too
because no one can make that big play to
kind of get them off the stride and turn
the momentum back their way
so back to the original point if it's
some sort of a wake-up call
is is it an alarm that they'll respond
to can they really fix it you know what
i'm saying i know i don't know
maybe maybe we thought we were better
than we are well guess what we're not
we're not better than we were this is
who we are what can we do on the fly i i
think it's just going to have to
continue to be like this is the formula
we have to continue to approach is play
our style of football where we're great
with our first 15 plays that lefor
drives up draws up to start the game and
they get out in those leads and then
they can preston smith zadaria smith and
send all crazy blitzes and play crazy
coverage but i think that's going to
have to be their main focal point yeah
they'll try to get better the things
they're not worse you know that they
struggled with yesterday but i do think
the main thing for them will be to stick
to that formula we've talked about they
need to play for a lead get you in that
spot there rogers will continue to be
efficient because you don't know if
they're gonna run or throw the ball and
they can kind of put you in a tough spot
and they can get a little crazy on
defense but yes i would worry about them
with a lot of teams in football they're
lucky in the nfc there's not a lot of
complete teams right now
we'll see what they're where that
conversation goes in in january
we need to pivot yeah broncos patriots
but i got to get something off my chest
that only i am going to care about but
i'm not going to be able to function
until i mention this yesterday was the
46th time in nfl history the final score
was 38 to 10. i've got a bad connotation
with 38 to 10. let me tell you a quick
story yeah december 22 1996 the 23rd
time in nfl history the final score was
38 to 10. for the first time ever i went
to a sports bar to watch the vikings i'm
having my entire vikings fandom flash
before my eyes now that i've annulled
the relationship yes i dragged my wife
there we got a three-month-old at home
we lined up a babysitter we go to the
sports bar well first of all i don't
factor in the possibility that packers
fans are going to be there which made an
unenjoyable experience from the start
game was tied 10 10 at the half i'm
thinking hey i mean this is a packers
team that went on to win the super bowl
vikings got a chance at lambeau field
final score 38 to 10. so anytime i see
38 to 10 now i remember that day where i
decided i'm never going to do that again
and i've never done it again since then
although now it doesn't matter
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports